はい では何か話したいこととか
はい  サティマントっていうのはラガンに対して使う言葉です
この場合は  この場合はですね
だから宇宙ジャンキーという言葉なんですけども
これ熱構てっていうニュアンスはあるんですか？ 熱構て？ないでしょうね
うん おゆうぎやっていうのはかなりポジティブ的に頑張ってるんだよって
はい 長田さん  これ歌的に言えばサティがある人々は頑張ってきてるんだよという歌なんですね
気づきのものは生きてるんだと
ゆうにゃてサティマント
ね ニケーテーラマンティテー
家に囚われているわけじゃないと
家に留まらず頑張っていると
白鳥のごとく 家から家
家も家を捨てていくでしょうという歌なんですね
なかなか美しい日本語になりませんだけど
私の訳では はい 他いろいろ話したいことがあったら
失敗すればするほど愛着があって
失敗 失敗すればするほど愛着が強くなる
下をすれば悟りから悟りの可能性がなくなる
先ほど伺った話なんですけれども
まあたくさん失敗した身なんですが
愛着が非常愛着が非常に強くなった場合
それを抑えるにはどう何に気をつけていったらいいでしょうか
うん あのまあ 人間一回だけじゃなくて何回も失敗しますから
あの だから失敗するってことというよりも
あんた失敗したらどうしたの？っていうことがなんですよ
大事なのは 失敗しない人はいませんよ
私ももう結構自慢じゃないんだけど
いくらでもありますからね
だからあの 我々やってることは何でも成功するわけじゃないしね
いいと思ったことはそうではなかったってことはいくらでもあるしね
だから現実的に喋れば失敗するということは0にする意味じゃないんです
どうせ人生は失敗の連続でしょうしね
そこで引っかかって止まったらあかんなんですね
それが問題なんです だから失敗したら
じゃあでもあんたどうする？ということなんです
どうするじゃん もう悔しい
今度はもう負けませんよという感じにならなくちゃいけない
例えばまあ失礼な例かもしれませんだけど
あの 25 で結婚してみて
まあ頑張ってみたんだけど
大失敗で 40 で別れたと
あんたどうすると言ったら悔しい
もう一度結婚してやるぞということではないんです
ものすごい悔しい いや
40歳にもなりましたし
まあこんなのはこりごり
別なことをやるぞと思ってればいいんです
だからその時自分が成功する道を発見するんですね
だから同じことを繰り返すって意味でもないんです
いい質問です そこら辺は一応現実的に説明した方がいいと思いますね
例えば東大受かろうとしましたけど
もう三 二回も失敗してまた悔しい三回目にやることが正しいか
いい加減やめて別なことやるかっていうのはね
いう道もあります あの日本の司法試験みたいに十回も十五回も毎年受け続けて
やっと十九回でもう試験を受けたとかね
まあそういうふうなことでいいのかと
もう年も取っていくんだからね
だから一回結婚して失敗したら
あっ 無理も悔しくて他の男を見つけて結婚してということ
それは成功する場合もあるし
ない場合もありますから
やっぱりまあまあ生き方がいろいろ様々まちまちになりはなります
だから現実的に考えればいいんです
あの失敗しない人生送ってくださいということを言ってるわけじゃないんです
生きること自体が失敗の連続以外何もないんです
だからまあ その失敗に対して私は何をするのかっていうことなんです
失敗で足が止まったらもう終わり
もうあれもできん これもできんことになっちゃうんです
精神的に落ち込んだらダメ
病気になったらダメなんです
そういうわけで 何か失敗してダメだなとか自己嫌悪に陥っている場合は
では自分で自分を褒めるために何やればいいかなと何か見つかることなんですね
例えば出家する人の場合でも
私にはこれ以上行くところがないんだからってホームがないんだからって
だったら成功するでしょう
だからホームがない場合は成功するんです
だからいいことを言うことを聞かない子供たちも
もうきれさっぱり勘当されると成功するでしょ
行くところなくなっちゃったんだから
もう成功するしかないんです
で 気が弱くてアメリカに留学に行ったんだけど
もう家が火事になって
もう両親も死んじゃったと
もう帰るところなくなっちゃったと
それだったらもうその人が
まあ人様々ですけど 行くところなくなっちゃった
じゃあアメリカでも何とかするしかないんだと
お母さんに自慢しようと思ってアメリカに来たんだけど
お母さんもいなくなっちゃったし
みんな死んじゃったし
まあもうもう私にはもういいや
こんな国も嫌 いたって面白くなんともない
アメリカで頑張るぞという場合は頑張れるんでしょうね
そう思えば なぜならば
行くところがなくなっちゃう
戻るところがなくなったんです
だからこのあなたにいちいち言われたってもという調子ではね
うまく行かないんです
俺には誰か誰かバックでいるんだぞという人々は成功しないんです
ま そういうふうなことで
あの落ち込んだらあかんですね
失敗するのは  それはごく普通な当たり前のことで
日本文化に引っかかってるかもしれないんだけど
そのよりどころっていうところで
例えばサンケーとかで言うところのよりどころと
この逃げてとか そういうところのよりどころとは一緒にもらえられるようには思わないんですけども
微妙に違うみたいな感じがするんですけど
教えていただけますでしょうか
あのサンケーさせるのも法務を捨てさせるためなんですね
正しいサンケー というのは
もう全部よりどころを捨てるんです
もう他へ行くところないんだと
仏法僧以外はというね
こちらで何とかしなきゃもう道がないんだと
だからあの面で似ていますよ
それで一切のよりどころは捨てなくちゃいけないんですね
それはまあスリランカの仏教徒なんかは三帰依しながらいろいろ神々に
あんなのはだらしなくてね
どうにもならんですね
例えば他宗教のもうそういう拝んでるお寺とかなったら
そういうところにいたらもう礼儀ですから
礼儀として頭を下げてやるべきことをやって
それはもう文化人の礼儀であって
そうじゃなくて これ真面目に信仰せているんですね
今日新聞で読んだんですけど
誰かのもうすごい田舎の一般の人が頑張って頑張って
もうお寺の学校で勉強して
それから大学受験が入学しないで受験を受けることもできます
で お寺の教育はいくらかレベルがありますから
それで大学も合格して
それから政治に参加して
今なんか大臣には大臣にはなっているんですね
で これ田舎の方で結構活発に頑張っている人で
この人のインタビューなんですね
一つの質問は あなたはもう神々に対してどんな気持ちでしょうか？という
ああ この地方を守っている
なんだらかんだら神様をすごい大事に信仰してますよとかね
それからこの会もこのお寺もこの会もね
ちゃんと信仰してそういうしきたりやってますよとか
すごい自慢げで お前何者なの？という感じになっちゃったんですけどね
それでも浮かんだことでね
やっぱりあの連中あんなもんなんですよ
で 仏法僧に帰依しながら神頼みもする
情けないんです 三帰依すれば神様助けてくれ
道の神様はなんだら神様とかね
あのキリスト教の神様では断言信仰してないんだけど
様々な神々は日本と同じくね
信仰しているんですね
各地方には氏神というかね
いるんですよ だからこの地方の神様は結構みんなその地方の人々を大事にするというね
まあだから三帰依すれば
もうそれであなたは全部みんなと縁を切ったことになりますよということはありますけど
仏教はあんまりそれは表では言わないんですね
三帰依自体すごい厳しいことなんです
もう仏陀 ブッダが言うこと以外何もやってはいけないということの約束なんです
しかし それが表に出さないんですね
出せ出せないんですね
そうすると他の宗教と同じくすごい排他的な宗教ではないかということになりますから
もう排他的じゃないんだから
一応仏教は開放的で自由な世界だからね
本人が納得するまでじーっと待っている
曖昧でいい加減でいたっても何も言いません
で もう気を長くして仏教を教えながらしっかりと納得するまで
まあじっと待っているのが仏教の在り方なんですね
だからああいうふうな現象が見えてきます
ですから三帰依 結局は仏法僧をよりどころにすることなんですね
よりどころに悟ったら
やっぱり道を教えるのは仏教でしょということで
それで確立するんですね
それで仏道があるんだということに納得いったら
それが法務の代わりになるんです
自分には仏道があるんだと
だからこんな何失敗したのに気にするもんかと
そんなのはどうでもいいと
私には仏道あると それは自分のことでしょうし
自分の仕事でしょうしね
言われてやるものでもないでしょうしね
だから極似てるんですね
似ていて似ていないという
えっと まああの 今の話
スミちゃん  スミちゃんじゃないですか
今の話に若干関係あるような部分なんですけど
例の自灯明法灯明の自灯明というところの話とはどういう感じの
同じですよ  同じですか
だから自分をよりどころにするというふうに訳しているでしょ
それで結局はもうそれになるんですね
だから仏道っていうのは自分の修行でしょうね
自分の体で修行するでしょう
自分の感覚を感じながら
自分の心に生まれる煩悩を見ながら
自分自身の無常を観察することだから
やっぱり研究課題は自分自身なんですね
外にないんですね それで悟りに達するのは自分自身でしょうし
家が家という観念が消えていくのは自分が感じる経験でしょうし
ああ 言るところが全部もう嘘でした
なくなったという感じになるでしょうしね
だからそこで あの お釈迦様がアッタディーパということは
この他宗教と比較的に言ってるんですね
あの神がやってくれるという世界でしょ
神を拝む 神が祝福をくれるということの宗教の世界ですからね
何かに頼るということは宗教の世界で
お釈迦様はそれものすごい正反対のことをおっしゃるんです
自 自灯明でしたっけ？アッタディーパという
だからこれはもう大胆な革命的な言葉なんです
しかし 自分と言っても何だとわからなくなっちゃいますから
次のことで法 何でしたっけ？法灯明と言うんです
それは具体的な話で法であると
だから自分イコール法にしているんです
それはなんか僕もちょっとこう
自灯法灯明でちょっと引っかかって
アーリー アーリーのというか
インド哲学の著名な人に聞いてもちゃんと答えができないんですよね
だから  それはでもですね
修行をすればということしかないと言えば
そういうことなんです
それのほうがね 世間の言葉としてはね
便利かもしれませんだけどね
私は世間の言葉じゃなくて
答えは答えなんですね
だから我々は修行するならば
この修行の宿題は何なのか
この自分 生きている自分なんですね
その場合は自分というのはただ言葉だけでね
生きているそのシステムなんですね
だからお釈迦様の法って何ですかというと
生きているこのシステムの説明なんですね
だから法イコール自己なんですよ
例えば執着から苦しみが生まれると言えば
どこで研究する？自分軸でしょ？だから執着から苦しみが生れるということは法
真理を教えたんだ 何ですか
物の見事にこちらにあるんですね
それが 渇愛であんた悩み羽目になりますよと言われるのは
お釈迦様の言葉で法なんですね
どこにあるかというと
こちらにあるんですね
渇愛で酷い目になってるのは自分だからね
ですからアッタディーパダンマディーパっていうのは同義語で
自分を透明にする 法を透明にするといったっても同じことをおっしゃっているんです
それは革命的な言葉で
一切の人類の宗教の世界を一言葉で切りさっぱり変えてるんです
世界の一切の宗教信仰の世界で
頼るな 頼るなという 頼るな
怠けるなというその二言ぐらいでいいですかね
頼るなと言えば頼るななんですね
少し分かりました ありがとうございました
もうちょっと説明すると
この何も要りません 我々の悟りに達するためには
全て揃ってます 体 だから頼る必要ないんです
悟りに必要な宿題は全てあるんです
もう条件も何でもかんでも悟りに達するということ
生きることは苦しみで苦しみであると発見することでしょう
生きているのは自分だから
これが発見難しいな アメリカに行けばわかるんですが
スウェーデン行けばわかるんですが
そんなアホなことはないんだと
だから場所は関係ない
自分でいる どこにいるの自分ですからね
だから頼るということは依存するということは初めから間違いで成り立ちませんよと
あれはブッダのものすごい大胆な言葉なんです
お釈迦様に言われたんだから
何のことなく 何かいい言葉だなと感じるだけで
本当の意味見ると こんな怖いことよくおっしゃったなと思うぐらいなんです
世界にあった ある これから起こる一切の宗教世界を全部一言葉でゴミにするんだから
だからそういう意味ですから
それはなかなか普通の知識人には読み取れないと思います
自己という言葉 辞書を引いたり
いろんな文献を調べたりするだけで
自己と自我が何が違いますか？とかね
それで漢文を調べるんです
それで自己 己と書いて
自我と書いて 自分と我と自分との違いは違うでしょうかとか
本当に 今日も心の時代で誰かさんがね
アジビジゴクという言葉の無間地獄という説明するはするはするは
この漢字の説明なんですね
それでアジビジゴクの説明にならんだけどね
隙間なく苦しみがあるとかね
隙間なく連続であれやこれやとかね
もう勘違いもいいところで
言葉だけ それだけ聞くならばね
それなりにまとめては喋ってはいたんですけど
すぐチャンネルを変えて
美しくなるためにこれ買ってくださいって
はい では終了いたします
[経典]ありがとうございます